rentrer tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet avec vous amadeus je vais demander
à mes chroniqueurs de se prononcer
faut-il interdire la chasse oui ou non
amadeus vous êtes animalistes vegan
antispécistes les créateurs du journal
de la cause animale autant dire que vous
répondez oui à la question avec divers
arguments je vous propose de répondre au
premier selon vous la chasse propose une
vision du monde qui n'a plus lieu d'être
c'est une pratique d'un autre temps tout
à fait on fait la chasse ça met en
lumière humain qui serait un dominant
prédateurs qui auraient comme égérie de
tuer et d'aimer et d'aimer le sang et la
mort et ça c'est pas c'est pas ça qui
est mal ce qui est mal c'est que en fait
cette vision du monde elle est en train
de détruire les principaux concernés qui
sont les animaux qui sont des victimes
innocentes qui n'ont commis aucun crime
qu'est ce qu'un sanglier qu'est ce qu'un
rennes at il fait et surtout elle ancre
un de mes parents aussi en péril
l'humanité pourquoi parce que tant qu'on
se prendre à nous les humains pour les
dominants pour les maîtres de la planète
et qu'on sera dans une logique en
troupeau centre et on sera en train
d'avoir une logique de domination de
prédation et de croire que tout ce qui
nous entoure et de la marchandise et en
fait on nous amène à notre destruction
tant qu'on sera pas dans une logique on
aura compris que la cause animale c'est
la cause non pas uniquement pour sauver
les animaux mais également pour sauver
notre humanité on n'aura rien compris
mais là vous êtes vous vous êtes
antispécistes et savoir il faut préciser
ce que c'est à dire vous mettez un signe
d'égalité en fait entre l'homme alors
l'animal s'est pas tu tout pas tout à
fait ça d'accord je voir votre position
à vous voilà c'est une sénégalité de
considération c'est à dire que je
considère que un autre être humain a le
droit de vivre et je considère qu'un
animal qui a également de la sentience
c'est-à-dire delà de la conscience
d'exister et de ressentir la douleur a
le droit de vivre mais je dis pas qu'on
est égal qu'il ya des gentils specis qui
pousse l'antispécisme jusqu'à l'égalité
parfaite en fait à votre cas maintenant
non alain péréa vous vous êtes député
heller em de l'eau des chasseurs vous
êtes co président du groupe chasse à
l'assemblée nationale donc forcément
vous répondez non mais avant que vous
répondiez cette première objection
d'amadeus est ce qu'on peut être député
et antiques chasseurs parce que les
chasseurs sont un lobby électoral très
important plus ou moins importants selon
les régions de france et c est ce que on
peut être député et sa fiche et anti
chasse mais sûre il y as d'aborder des
groupes politiques à l'assemblée
nationale qui sont et qui s'affiche
totalement anti chasse 1 quand il s'agit
de signer des propositions de loi ils y
vont tous comme un seul homme donc déjà
des groupes et ensuite vous avez certain
nombre de députés d'ailleurs deux de
plus en plus je dirais qu'ils
s'expriment de plus en plus qui sont de
plus en plus revendicatif et ils ont le
droit parce que l'assemblée nationale
s'est contrairement à ce que certains
veulent dire c'est la représentation du
peuple donc dans le peuple il y à des
personnes qui sont anti chasse et ils
sont quoi qu'on en dise rose représentés
à l'assemblée nationale voilà un premier
point d'établir alors qu'est ce que vous
répondez amadéus en fait amadeus en fait
sont coincés les chasseurs sont des
tueurs des prédateurs non mais il faut
passer à autre chose parce que vous êtes
obsolète vous êtes les représentants
d'un âge révolu moi ce que j'ai envie de
lui dire et ce sur quoi je voudrais
appuyé c'est qu'il dise il définit ce
qu'est le bien et le mal est donc en
fait on voit bien que derrière il y a au
delà des arguments devant débattre
pendant un moment mais il n'y a aucun
argument actuelle on est uniquement sur
moi je considère que ça c'est bien et ça
c'est mal et on voit bien derrière avec
tous les mouvements que l'on peut avoir
au tour qu'il soit antispécistes qu'il
soit écologiste dur que derrière c'est
une vraie à la fois un vrai projet de
société qui n'est pas le projet de
société que je défends et odeurs et de
la ce et j'ai presque envie de dire une
nouvelle religion et on voit bien dans
la façon dont il fonctionne et dès le
début il a dit c'est mal et donc on a
cette approche qui est une approche
quasi d'une nouvelle religion et moi je
d'abord je suis bien entendu pour être
honnête j'ai pas entendu un discours
religieux j'ai entendu quelqu'un qui dit
se sont bien d'être vivant sensible il
est temps de les traiter autrement et
c'est mal et c'est mal c'est mal de les
tuer et bien c'est de ne pas les tuer
donc quand on commence à définir le bien
et le mal revenir on est dedans
construction d'une religion envie de
vous demander monsieur nous on a un
projet mais vous quel est votre projet
on est à la sixième extinction de masse
des espèces sauvages vous vous tuez des
espèces sauvages quel est votre projet
vous vous dites les premiers écologistes
de france quel est votre projet pour
l'écologie quel est votre projet face
aux espèces qui sont en voie de
disparition
vous continuez de les tuer à 91 espèces
chassables en france c'est le pays où il
y a plus le plus d'espèces chassables
sur ses 91 à peu près un tiers sont dans
des situations en voie de disparition et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est ce que vous
proposez etc et voilà ou alors moi je
vous dis un truc
[Applaudissements]
le projet je rêvais que monsieur
naulleau me pose cette question et vous
me faites un cadeau vous me reposez moi
je rêve que dans ce pays nous puissions
être des hommes et des femmes libres
sibra libre de pouvoir continuer à
pratiquer un certain nombre de la nature
en libre de pratiquer un certain nombre
de cultures de pouvoir pratiquer un
certain nombre de traditions qui font
que nous sommes tous ici je suis à dire
qu'elles ont existé et que à un moment
donné s'ils ont envie de chasser ils
peuvent chasser s'ils ont envie d'être
vega nilsson légal s'ils ont pas envie
d'être vegan il ne saurait gâcher
voulait donc et donc moi là dessus je
suis je suis pour que nous puissions
dans ce pays continue avec revivre à
vivre libre et vu votre projet votre
projet c'est d'être dans le conformisme
il faut que l'on soit tous pareils il
faut que l'on mange tous pareils il faut
que nous parlions la même façon et donc
mon projet politique c'est de continuer
à faire ce qui a fait de la france un
modèle ambitieux un modèle de cas
secondaires de riches villas
frappé vous voulez le tuer
il faudra nous expliquer si elles sont
mises en danger pour la france ou si
elles sont mises à dribler monsieur
parce qu'il a une objection ce qu'une de
vos objections c'est de viande non ce
n'est pas une tradition c'est un loisir
et donc il faut le traiter comme un
loisir contrairement à ce que vient dire
monsieur le député et donc ça a été une
tradition mais la tradition service
parle de la situation actuelle selon
vous à la tradition ça n'a strictement
aucune valeur argumentatif en tant que
tel parce que sinon on peut justifier
pas l'excision n'importe quoi au nom de
la tradition tradition arguments 0
poubelle on oublie ensuite la ligue il
dit ou alors vous choisirez les speakers
ceux qui la pratiquent ce traditionnel
l'éthique ensuite la liberté la liberté
vive la liberté mais il faut regarder
les conséquences de cette liberté la
chaste une activité récréative c'est un
amusement qui consiste à aller tuer des
animaux sauvages sauvage où la chai
d'élevage puisque un animal sur carla
revenir là dessus et panache à savoir
rien d'un corner algérien à partir du
moment où on permet qu'une liberté
s'exerce et que cette liberté génère de
la souffrance à des animaux qui ne sont
pas protégés par la loi parce que la loi
en france fait une distinction radicale
entre les animaux dits domestiques de
compagnie que les animaux 10 baj à
partir de là par exemple quand on fait
souffrir quand tu n'es pas un châssis
moi je décide de l'ancien de lancer un
chaton contre les murs il va s'offrir
cet animal si je tue un chien un chat en
ma présence je vous dis jeune et très
sensible à la cause de sa ville il est
justement mais c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que si je fais ça je
vais aller en prison parce que c'est du
pénal et heureusement mais si j'ai eu la
même chose sur un renard je peux le
faire non seulement je peux le faire et
je suis couvert en tant que chasseur il
suffit d'avoir un permis de chasse donc
je suis encouragé par les autorités qui
largement font en sorte que chacun
puisse en prenant un permis de chasse en
ayant un fusil infligé de la souffrance
est tué de façon parfaitement inutile
donc la liberté
belles valeurs auxquelles on est tous
sensibles il faut regarder les limites
de cette liberté si vous décidez de
faire souffrir un animal par exemple un
renard qui ressent la douleur exactement
comme un humain ou un chien parce que
cela leur avait ri de nous si ça vous
lance un dernier message mais des choses
ils ont la science est passée par là il
faut un petit peu regardé la science et
d'histoire des sciences sociales en la
souffrance animale c'est pas la chute à
elle existe et ce n'est pas discutable
se terminer quand il de maintenir jusque
les animaux ressemble exactement les
mêmes choses que les êtres humains on
rentre dans une stratégie qui est que
nous tous nous rendre se sentir leur
meute ils avaient agressé par les
méchants chasseurs n'ont pas dehors on
ne laissera pas
compter sur la très populaire ici les
petits lapins c'est pas bien sûr c'est
un vraiment sur cet argument de la
liberté ça génère de la souffrance
inutile aux animaux car il est
parfaitement inutile d'aller tuer un
renard et ça le tue alors c'est
parfaitement inutile de le tuer dire que
dire des conséquences écologiques sur la
biodiversité avec des espèces menacées
en déclin souvent pour d'autres facteurs
et voulait qu'elle en rajoute un facteur
d'élimination qui est la chasse et ça
génère parce que c'est une chasse de
loisirs et qu'il suffit d'avoir un
permis de chasse qui est assez facile à
obtenir un dérangement dans les
campagnes et c'est pour ça que les gens
la convalescence est votre ignorance
parce que je suis patient est en panne
ce centre est dérangeant
sondages les gens de la campagne les
gens de la campagne sont majoritairement
hostiles à
15% des
dérangés par la jeunesse je peux finir à
60% des personnes habitant aux alentours
de zones de chasse aux alentours de
zones de chasse
75% des personnes habitant aux alentours
de zones de chasse et un essor et 2
d'aller en fonderie à skhira qu'on
attendait un autre
vous avez quoi 100% d'eads en tirant ce
sens qui contre la chasse aussi
désigné par votre avis à ce fait nous
chasser
c'est comme ça qu'on les rapporte quoi
qui vont intervenir les déjà intervenir
vous pour appeler à me chez amadeus que
déjà leur haine leur haine c'est ce qui
tire le traîneau du père noël leur haine
s'est élevé par les élevages sami dans
les norvégiens en suède il n'est pas
chassé en europe bon voila mais c'est la
non mais c'est pas grave après c'est
juste ça montre un petit peu la
profondeur de vos connaissances vous
voulez haut niveau ça va vite très très
il n'y a pas de souci par le chargé on
est là pour les chats sont là et puis
après moi il ya quelque chose que j'ai
lu et kim a un qui m'interrogent
particulièrement vous m'arrêtez si je me
trompe mais
j'ai lu donc sur votre
sur un site que vous avez écrit espoir
espoir vegan point net oui que vous
aviez un passif de délinquants que votre
gagne pain était de vendre des armes de
manière illégale dans la cité sais que
vous avez beaucoup appris d'un carénage
et de me dire et après c'est ma
rédemption
je vais terminer je vais terminer
des valeurs d'un caïd de cité qui
sortait de prison allez sur le fond nous
tient par contre j'y arrive j'y arrive
pas le disque ali
[Musique]
je finirai fonction avez vous dire ce
qu'elle n'est pas c'est une émission de
règlements de comptes non mais c'est pas
ce qu'on a mais rester sur le ml je suis
exactement le fond mais laissera faire
le lien avec le font donc chez votre
grand mère visiblement vous auriez vu un
reportage un jour sur un documentaire
et vous êtes devenu vegan est ce que
c'est vrai vous êtes chez vous et vous
vous aimez vous est mauvais est ému
allez vous êtes ému de voir un lyon
manger une gazelle du coup vous devenez
végal mais ça vous dérange soin d'avoir
un monde et art et
c'est le temps que c'est par exemple
pour tué bambi ça vous passez pas de
poil à part vous me faites un très beau
cadeau messieurs ça pour ça
si ça choque pas aucun rider reste que
monsieur madoff avait rien
j'avais rien de quelqu'un qui pouvait
devenir vegan de quelqu'un qui pouvait
aimer les animaux j'avais rien de cela
et c'est grâce à votre description mais
les critères montré que déjà regagné
mais les agrégats et aimer les animaux
c'est pour tout le monde c'est pas
uniquement à parts égales et les bobos
parisiens je sais pas vous êtes en train
de prendre le débat en otage c'est ce
monsieur dit nous répondait aux autres
sections contraire en fait moi je m'en
fous des cv des invités pardonnez moi je
vais vous dire quelque chose sur ce
weed et qui se retourne sur le sujet on
va parler d'écologie là l'écologie c'est
important et on a son l'a souvent dit ça
fait parfois sourire qu'on était les
premiers écologistes de france et ça
surprend beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui
qu'on peut gérer avec des fusils et
qu'on peut être associations de
protection de la nature et est chasseur
c'est le cas bah oui tu peut applaudir
deuxièmement du coup en plus on a une
théorie qui est très très répandue et
qui fait de plus en plus de bruit c'est
là la conservation part par
l'utilisation en fait c'est une théorie
très importante qui montrent que à
partir du moment où on a un intérêt dans
les ressources en eau c'est de la
gestion durable on va les défendre et on
va les défendre on va faire un
l'essentiel pour que cette question soit
durable et qu'on puisse transmettre
cette passion des enfants quand vous
êtes passionné de vélo vous n'avez pas
le entretenir n'importe comment vous
n'avez pas le [ __ ] en l'air et bien la
chasse est exactement la même chose et
on est les premiers sur le terrain il ya
un million de déco citoyens qui font
qu'ils font énormément de choses sur
jafar de chasseurs mais mais on est
considérés comme les écossais
on fait d'écologie terrain ont fait pas
l'écologie et chalon sous les principaux
écologie s'est il entendu